what a year boy wow started with the flu
ending with a coup
and spin-off
oh my god i mean people know this you
know there's like five stages of grief
after a loss yeah everyone knows this
denial
anger bargaining depression acceptance i
don't want to name names but
somebody seems stuck on the first two
because this this has been the most
drawn out transition since caitlyn
jenner
[Applause]
i mean trump i we thought he was a
russian plant turns out he's an irish
relative
yeah this guy reminds me of the remember
the movie the sixth sense
you remember that movie the main
character doesn't know he's dead
hey no really if this president if this
presidency was a bar
it is way past closing time
we need that guy who goes you don't have
to go home but you can't stay here
uh but you know the president
is making an interesting case uh for
himself he's saying he's uncovered a
conspiracy a widespread
conspiracy involving tens of millions of
americans
voting for his opponent
really that's his case his case is
basically if you don't count all those
votes for biden i won by a landslide
that's as much as i can glean
and also the will of the people very
unfair
very un but don't ever say these people
don't try
i mean the president has been sending
out his rudy giuliani
went to that's a laugh itself isn't it
went to contest the vote in uh
pennsylvania they said it was going to
be at the four seasons philadelphia
it was at a four seasons total
landscaping
i'm not joking about i wish i was this
would make a great sketch
it was in a [ __ ] home depot where was
going to bring out witnesses to the
fraud one of the witnesses
to the voter fraud that giuliani brought
out didn't even live in pennsylvania
and turned out to be a sex offender
yeah when they offered him the job of
poll watcher
he thought they meant something
completely different
but don't think that just because all
this is going on the president has
stopped presidenting
because wednesday was veterans day and
trump visited the tomb of the unknown
soldier
and accused him of voting illegally
you